do you want me to skip james harden yes
or no i could skip james harden
i got scared i don't know i i could talk
i got skipping
you don't have to just kiss just hold
this skipper okay
because no because last time we talked
about him i know you were like you were
like dude
ain't nothing changed but i think the
one thing that has changed over the last
couple of days
well i'm confused about it but i'm gonna
tell you in a second is john wall
looked really good in his first two
preseason games
john wall looked uh looked spry he
looked fresh
he just he looked like he was poised to
have a great season talk about people
it's good to see back
steph throw steph curry now if you want
but john wall two years
and and now here he is it's just good to
see him back on the floor
looking like the old john wall but what
confuses me though
is at one point i thought that kevin
durant
excuse me that james harden preferred
john wall
over russell westbrook according to
reports at this point i forget who
reported it
but then today woj and ramona shelburne
report that
he is unmoved and uninterested
and continuing on
and continuing don't y'all understand
despite yeah
he still wants out so what do you make
of that
i think he's uh what what was he uh what
was the feed item
one of my favorite feed feed items so
far i think he's stuck like
chuck is that is that what you called
last week yeah
he is he knows it and i think he knows
he's got two years left on this contract
and there aren't many places that are
just
going to dismantle what they have to
accommodate them
right or there's a place that's a trade
and kyrie
they or the places that want to do that
they can't
now you know i saw one story where miami
there's a mutual interest between james
harden and miami
and that tyler hero is not a deal
breaker i wouldn't think he would be a
deal breaker
for james harden but it's not going to
work
you can have mutual interest he's got a
huge contract
and it's not like uh it's not like you
can
you can kind of tear that that take that
contract apart
piece by piece and say all right uh take
30
or 40 less right now we'll take care of
you next year it's a contract that's in
place
you're moving contracts in the nba
you're not moving players you're moving
contracts
and it's just going to be difficult to
trade him to a place
that he's comfortable being so i think
he's just trying to he
is or his representatives are just
trying to get the story out
hey he's ready to be moved nothing has
changed
but yeah the bad news for him is nothing
has changed
who's got the cap space you're going to
have to you're going to have to mike
orchestrate a three or four team trade
to get him out of here to get the people
where he wants houston wants speaking
real quick uh you know so harden's going
to play tuesday apparently miraculously
quite honestly but thankfully
uh he's passed i guess six straight
covid tests
you know um so he's gonna play on
tuesday
but to your point uh about just kind of
like just getting the word out
this paragraph from uh the espn article
uh stood out to me so
it says uh after detouring or detouring
excuse me the social engagements in
atlanta
and las vegas before reporting late for
training camp last week
uh hardin has expressed to rockets
ownership and management his intention
to be professional
and engaged upon joining the team for
the rockets this is necessary for the
team to operate under new coach steven
silas
while also allowing for some leverage in
the trade market to get closer
to full value for harden the appearance
of a distressed asset
only hinders an organization in making a
trade of this magnitude
and hardness expressed understanding of
this concept as well as the idea that it
may take time to find a trade that
returns appropriate value to the rockets
hook the people the transition
hook the people up in the translation
what does that mean break it down go
ahead
uh that means he's stuck like chuck and
he knows it and it's always choice
that's
that's that's first definition suck like
chuck here's a second definition
they sat him down and said look james i
know you want to be traded
but the more you do these things it's
harder for us to move you
so if you want to if you want us to
trade you you're going to have to you
have to dial it back a little bit all
right
okay that's what happened yeah but i'll
be honest with you though i'm not even
first of all it's like professional and
gay and engaged
gee thanks appreciate you how
considerate of you after showing up late
for training camp
thank you for coming in to be
professional and engaged
what a concept okay yeah i don't even
know that that makes him a distressed
asset
if he's disgruntled i think the main
thing for these teams
is everything that we've talked about
which is can somebody put together the
kind of package that houston wants
and is that somebody somewhere
where james will stay beyond his player
option
like if he's unhappy or not i don't
think anybody's gonna be like you know
what i ain't trading for him because he
was unhappy in houston and he didn't
show up on time
like he still a three-time scoring
champion mvp if someone would be so
inclined
to dismantle their roster in order to
accommodate him hey thanks for watching
brother from another on youtube
make sure you hit subscribe before you
leave and be sure to watch us
3 to 5 p.m eastern time on peacock
appreciate you